some spiders helpfully Chow Down on
these blood sucking pests so we should
be thanking
them if we killed all spiders we would
see a huge population surge in these
nasty bugs and the diseases they spread
like malaria zika virus and Deni
fever while birds and bats also eat
insects spiders are the true insect
control
extraordinaires without them Creepy
Crawlers would flourish which would be
bad news for our food
system cereal crops like oats wheat corn
rye and potatoes would be the first to
succumb to the hoorde of uncontrolled
insects we would have to ramp up
pesticide use quickly which poses its
own threat to humans in the
environment